the goated sentinel agent killjoy sent
the valerian community into a frenzy and
it wasn't with her lockdowns or random
molly lineups it was with a tweet that
linked her to nfts
[Music]
all right y'all before i get into the
video i gotta remind you as always the
like and subscribe button as well as to
ring that notification bell if you don't
you will never get to hear my killjoy
impression so if you're addicted to
twitter like me one we should get some
help two you've probably seen valerian's
latest social media adventure where they
kind of take us through a tour of each
agent's world basically in these tours
we get to know the agents better via
tweets that give us a peek into their
daily lives super cute super fun so far
we've seen rayna chamber and my lovely
beaver perfect cannot change her to be
any better mane kill joy
at all of this fun
i don't know any german but wow she sure
looks like she's having a good time so
you get the idea right helps to add a
little more depth to the asians that we
know and love but with all of these
tweets that i'm showing you there is one
missing there was a tweet that showed
our favorite tech quiz at some sort of
art gallery it looks like regardless
she's staring at some art looks to be
completely normal right except people
took issue with the art she was enjoying
killjoy or rather the person behind the
tweets wrote that this art was by martin
haura martin haura is indeed an artist
and you can see a lot of his work on his
instagram page that looks a lot like
what killjoy was enjoying however a
closer look at this person shows that
there's something particular about
martin howard's art some of the art he
makes specifically his solar collection
that is pretty similar to what killjoy
is looking at is available on the
ethereum blockchain basically martin
harrah is an artist who creates what
many would call nfts so when this tweet
was seen there was a response people
were upset that riot would even consider
supporting nfts some were upset at riot
specifically for making killjoy support
nfts but eventually the tweet was taken
down and we got an explanation in
english and german since killjoy loves
programming we wanted to introduce you
to computer-generated art around the
world however we were not aware that the
selected work wasn't nft in no way did
we intend to include nfts as a part of
killjoy's work and hobbies
so there you have it official lore for
killjoy she is not involved in nfts
it's a little funny that ray even had to
clarify this but hey at least now we
know and honestly if any agent would be
into nfts it would be like
breech
or phoenix
or both
headshot oh that was really good that
was oh that one that one's that one was
really good
uh what else does he say uh
hello
rotating i'm rotating
uh
cypher can you shoot me
cypher can you show me around the dark
web sometime